[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YES.
HERE WE ARE.
HAPPY MONDAY EVERYONE.
OR AS SHE LIKES TO CALL IT, IV
DRIP DAY.
BECAUSE HER WEEKENDS ARE A
LITTLE ROUGH.
THIS SHOW IS DOING GREAT, AND I
KNOW THIS BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
READ THE MAIL.
WELL, MY YOUNG ASSISTANT READS
THEM TO ME AS I LAY IN MY
HAMMOCK.
HE ACTUALLY SHOOTS THEM AT ME.
QUITE A TALENT.
AND A LOT OF THE MAIL SAYS GREG,
THIS SHOW IS DOING GREAT.
ALSO, DUDE, YOU HAVE REALLY BEEN
WORKING OUT.
AND WOW, IT'S LIKE YOU GET
TALLER EVERY DAY.
SIGNED, NEIL PATRICK HARRIS.
BUT I GET OF FEW COMPLAINTS.
A LOT ABOUT NOT ENOUGH CAMERA
SHOTS OF HER FEET.
I FORGOT TAKE FOR ALL MIKE GAVE
BARNEY MY EMAIL.
BUT MOSTLY IT'S ABOUT SWEARING.
WE SWEAR TOO MUCH ON THE SHOW.
AND I AGREE.
SWEARING CAN GET AN EASY LAUGH
AND IT FEELS GOOD.
BUT I DON'T LIKE IT WHEN WE
OVERDO IT.
SO WHY AM I SAYING THIS?
BECAUSE WE ARE [BLEEP] --
THERE IS NO OTHER WORD TO
DESCRIBE THIS CURRENT SITUATION
WE ARE IN.
[BLEEP] THINK ABOUT IT.
AS WE CRIMINALIZE EVERYTHING, WE
DECRIMINALIZE CRIMINALS.
AS WE TARGET PEOPLE TRYING TO
PROTECT THEIR KIDS, WE PROTECT
THOSE TRYING TO TARGET US.
WE ARE LIVING IN A TIME WHERE WE
PLAYED CATCH AND RELEASE WITH
DERANGED CRIMINALS, TAKING THEM
UP AND THEN TOSSING THEM BACK
INTO THE GENERAL POPULATION LIKE
A FISHERMAN RELEASING AN
UNDERWEIGHT BASS.
IT IS NOW A GAME OF RUSSIAN
ROULETTE.
THE GOVERNMENT IS THE GUN, THE
BOWL IS THE CRIMINAL, AND YOU
ARE THE TARGET.
MEANWHILE, THEY LIVE IN THEIR
SAFE EDGE WASHING ""SQUID GAME""
ON NETFLIX, A DRUMMER FROM
SOUTH KOREA WHERE PEOPLE ARE
RANDOMLY KILLED IN THAT SERIES
CHILDREN'S GAMES.
THINK HIDE AND GO SEEK WITH
MACHETES.
I ENJOYED THE FIRST EPISODE BUT
THEN I WAS DONE BECAUSE I DIDN'T
NEED TO WATCH IT.
I CAN JUST WALK OUTSIDE AND SEE
IT FOR REAL ON MY STREETS.
JERMAINE FOSTER, A SICK MANIAC
WHO HAD JUST ALLEGEDLY ROBBED
ONE WOMAN ON SATURDAY AND
KNOCKED ANOTHER ONE TO THE
GROUND.
A 58-YEAR-OLD CANCER NURSE.
SHE FELL, SUFFERED A MORTAL HEAD
WOUND, AND DIED A DAY LATER.
THIS OCCURRED IN THE AFTERNOON
IN TIMES SQUARE.
YOU KNOW, THE ONLY TIME DECENT
PEOPLE WILL VENTURE THERE.
IT WAS ONCE THE NUMBER ONE
TOURIST CAPITAL, BUT NOW IT IS
""SQUID GAME"."
EVERYONE IS A VICTIM, OR WEARING
AN ELBOW COSTUME.
HERE COMES THE SECOND PART OF
THE STORY.
LIKE CLOCKWORK.
THE THIEF HAS BEEN RESTED BEFORE
BUT WAS RELEASED.
SO TELL ME AGAIN HOW RACIST THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS.
MAYBE THE MIDDLE-AGED FILIPINO
WOMAN, NAILED ON A GROPING
CHARGE AND MOST LIKE OTHER
HEINOUS THUGS, THE VICTIMS WERE
WOMEN.
THIS STORY GETS REPEATED MORE
OFTEN THAN SEINFELD.
IF HE HAD BEEN JAILED AND
RECEIVED THE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT THAT WE PAID FOR, THIS
WILL NOT HAVE HAPPENED.
LIKE WHEN A REPUBLICAN WAS
MAYOR.
BUT DID YOU KNOW THE CURRENT
MAYOR'S WIFE RENTED $800 MILLION
-- DESIGNED TO HELP MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE.
IT IS ONLY HELP TO GO SO FAR.
THE MAYOR AND HIS WIFE.
THERE IS MORE NUTS ON THE STREET
NOW THAN AFTER AN EXPLOSION AT
THE PLANTER'S FACTORY.
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS, NO
ONE KNOWS WHERE THE MONEY WENT.
I THINK PATIO, FURNITURE, AND
WEED.
MEANWHILE THE MAYOR'S SON GETS
CHAUFFEURED BY ACTUAL DETECTIVES
TO AND FROM THE DRUGSTORE.
MAKE SENSE.
THE BOSS de BLASIO DOES NOT
WANT A SON TO BE A VICTIM OF THE
CRIME WAVE HE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR.
THIS IS ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND --
YET FLAT AUTHORS HAVE MORE
EVIDENCE IN SUPPORT OF ITS
CLAIM.
AS REAL HOMICIDE RATES
SKYROCKET, HE IS FOCUSING ON
CLAIMS OF HARASSMENT AGAINST
SCHOOL BOARDS.
YEAH.
HE IS RIGHT.
YOU'VE SEEN ALL THOSE VIDEOS OF
PARENTS FOLLOWING TEACHERS INTO
BATHROOMS WITH THEIR
CELL PHONES.
SCREAMING AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS WHILE THEY ARE TRYING TO
HAVE A QUIET DINNER IN A
RESTAURANT.
GOING TO PEOPLE'S HOMES AND
CHANTING WITH BULLHORNS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
OH WAIT, THAT IS HIS TEAM.
SO LET'S IMAGINE WHERE THIS
MIGHT END UP.
SPEAK OUT WHAT ARE IN FOR?
>> I MURDERED A GUY.
HOW ABOUT YOU?
>> I ASKED A QUESTION ABOUT
MASKS AT A SCHOOL BOARD MEETING.
>> ALL RIGHT INMATE, BACK TO IT.
>> WHAT ABOUT MY BABY?
>> HE WILL RAISE HIM.
>> HEY, HE MURDERED PEOPLE.
>> JUST ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THOSE ARE BETTER THAN
NEW YORKER CARTOONS.
SO PERHAPS IT'S A GAME OF
DEFLECTION.
CREATE MASS HYSTERIA FOR A FREE
PROBLEM TO DISTRACT FROM THE
REAL PROBLEMS.
IT IS HARD TO GET DISTRACTED
FROM YOUR STOLEN CARS,'S"
BUSINESS, AND I FLUENT.
BUT PEOPLE KEEP DYING AND THEY
DON'T MATTER BECAUSE THEIR
SUFFERING SERVES NO POLITICAL
PURPOSE.
THEIR LIVES DON'T MATTER TO
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
SO REAL CRIMINALS RUN FREE LIKE
MOOSE IN ALASKA AND PARENTS OF
ALL COLORS GET DEMONIZED FOR
CARING ABOUT THEIR KIDS
EDUCATION.
WHAT ARE YOU LEFT WITH?
AN ACTIVIST GOVERNMENT CREATING
ACTIVIST PARENTS FOR THE SUREST
WAY TO RED PILL HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS IS TO CALL THEM
TERRORISTS IN THE SECOND SUREST
WAY IS TO PROTECT THE THUGS AS
YOU DO THAT.
PUT ALL OF US IN HARM'S WAY AND
NOW THE TYPE TURNS.
A RED TIDE IF YOU WELL.
AND LIKE A RED TIDE, SMALL
ANTIGOVERNMENT ACTIVIST GROUPS
ARE GOING TO COME TO THE SURFACE
CHAIM BLOOM.
WE HAVE SEEN MOVEMENTS AND GO
THE TEA PARTY, BLACK LIVES
MATTER, LINE DANCING.
IT IS TIME FOR A PARENT MOVEMENT
THAT STANDS UP TO THIS BALL
MOVEMENT WE CALL THE GOVERNMENT.
SAFE STREETS AND GOOD SCHOOLS
ARE A POPULAR IDEA THAT NO
MATTER WHAT NEWS CHANNEL YOU
WATCH.
AND WHY PAY TAXES TO A
GOVERNMENT THAT CHOOSES THE SIDE
THE VICTIM VICTIMIZES YOU.
IT'S LIKE GIVING THE SCHOOLYARD
BULLY YOUR LUNCH MONEY OUT
DOMINIC DAY AFTER DAY.
THEY SEE YOU AS A BIGGER THREAT
THAN AL QAEDA WHILE CITIZENS GET
MURDERED IN BROAD DAY RIGHT.
IT IS TIME FOR A NEW BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
COLLECT ALL LIVES MATTER.
OH, BUT THAT IS RACIST, GREG.
OH, GO [BLEEP] YOURSELF.
SORRY.
SORRY THAT I SWORE AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR ANY FUTURE
SWEARING.
BUT IT IS TIME WE GAVE [BLEEP]
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T WE WON'T
HAVE ANY LEFT TO GIVE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
WHEN SHE SAYS TICKETS TO THE GUN
SHOW, SHE MEANS --
LARA TRUMP.
HE HAS A STAR'S NAME AND A LEGO
FIGURES HERA.
RADIO AND BROADCAST HOSTS BUCK
SEXTON.
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT NO LONGER
RESPONSE WHEN THIS KAT GET STUCK
IN A TREE.
KAT TIMPF.
AND HE IS STRONG ENOUGH TO BEAT
YOU IN WRESTLING AND SMART
ENOUGH TO CORRECT YOUR SPELLING.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
SO, LARA, I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
COURSE IN FRONT OF YOU.
>> I'M HIGHLY OFFENDED.
I'M GOING TO GO.
>> Greg: BEFORE YOU DO, WHY
DON'T YOU GLOAT A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE LEFT NEW YORK.
YOU ARE GONE.
BUT THIS IS NOT JUST NEW YORK.
THIS IS HAPPENING IN A LOT OF
CITIES.
>> AND YOU SEE WHY.
YOU JUST LAID OUT THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE REASON THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE LEFT NEW YORK, HAVE
LEFT CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE ARE MOVING CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATES -- CONGRESSIONAL
SEATS IN STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO LIVE LIKE THIS.
YOU SAID IT EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU WANT SAFE STREETS, YOU WANT
TO GOOD SCHOOLS FOR YOUR KIDS,
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT, WHY
WOULD YOU STAY IN A PLACE?
AND PEOPLE AREN'T.
AND I AM PROUDLY A FLORIDA
RESIDENT NOW.
I COME BACK FROM TIME TO TIME
JUST TO DO "GUTFELD!" BECAUSE
IT'S THE GREATEST SHOW ON
LATE-NIGHT TV.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: GREATEST SHOW ON TV.
>> PERIOD.
BUT IT TRULY IS.
IT'S SO SAD TO SEE WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
CITIES LIKE NEW YORK WHICH USED
TO BE THE GREATEST --
>> Greg: WE HAVE GREAT
RESTAURANTS AND GREAT BROADWAY
SHOWS.
AND YOU REALLY CAN'T SAY THAT
ANYMORE BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
RESTAURANTS AREN'T OPEN.
I HAVE BETTER QUESTION.
BECAUSE YOU ARE SMARTISH.
YEAH.
I CUE ABOUT 170 MAY BE.
WHY CAN'T WE STOP CATCH AND
RELEASE ON WIRE THE
FACILITATION'S IN THE CITY'S
DOING ANYTHING ABOUT THIS?
>> PEOPLE KEEP FOCUSING ON D
FROM THE POLICE WHICH IS
HORRIBLE AND NOW THEY ARE
ACTUALLY REFUNDING POLICE LIKE
AUSTIN WITH A CUT THE BUDGET BY
100 MILLION AND THEY HAD THEIR
HIGHEST EVER YEAR OF MURDERS AND
THIS IS TRUE CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
BUT IT'S PROSECUTORS OFFICES AS
WELL.
I'VE A FRIEND OF THE
NEW YORK CITY'S DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OFFICE AND THEY WON'T
PROSECUTE MORE MINOR CRIMES
BECAUSE THEY ARE GETTING
PRESSURE ABOVE, THE POLITICAL
WINDS HAVE CHANGED SO MUCH, THAT
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO ENFORCE
A LOT OF THESE LAWS.
IF YOU GO TO THE PLACE ON THE
CORNER, EVERYTHING IN HIS IN
PLASTIC.
IF YOU WANT TO GET FOR DIFFERENT
THINGS COMING UP TWO PLUS A
LITTLE BUTTON AND THEN THE
TIRED, ANNOYED EMPLOYEE HAS TO
COME AND OPENED UP FOR YOU
SLOWLY.
I GO TO WORK EVERY DAY AND TAPE
A TV SHOW IT NEXT TO WHAT IS ONE
OF THOSE HOMELESS SHELTERS THAT
IS ACTUALLY A HOTEL THAT THE
FOLKS HERE ARE PAYING FOR THE
TAXES AND IT'S OUT IN FRONT OF
ME AND IT'S LIKE A REFUGEE CAMP.
PEOPLE ARE COOKING FOOD, SMOKING
WEED, OPEN AIR.
>> Greg: YOU ARE WALKING
AROUND?
>> NOT GOING.
NO.
>> Greg: DON'T JUMP TO SOME
CONCLUSIONS JUST YET.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A HELL OF A TIME.
I THINK THERE IS A CERTAIN
COZINESS BETWEEN THESE HOTELS
AND THE POLITICIANS.
THEY ARE FULL AND GETTING THE
FULL PRICE I BET.
>> ALL THE USUAL RULES OF THE
QUALITY OF LIGHT STUFF, THE
BROKEN WINDOWS.
NONE OF THAT STUFF MATTERS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE ONCE YOU STOP
ENFORCING SENATOR BENNET, THERE
ARE MAD MAX STYLE DRAG RACES
WITH ALL THE LEGAL VEHICLES AND
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE THEY ARE FROM
MAD MAX.
ATVs WITH SPIKES ON THE SIDE.
>> Greg: I'VE SEEN ON A
SIDEWALK WHEN THEY ARE UP
SIDEWALKS.
>> THAT WAS ME.
YOU SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN OUT OF
THE WAY.
>> Greg: EXCEPT YOU ARE
SHIRTLESS.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST CRIME
INCREASE IN MY LIFETIME.
AND GRANTED, I AM ONLY 35.
BUT STILL IT IS VERY DRAMATIC
AND DOES A WOMAN, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT THIS?
THAT'S A REALLY GENERIC
QUESTION.
>> I AM A WOMAN.
AND I FEEL IN THIS ESSAY I WILL
-- SO I DON'T LIKE THAT I CAN'T
GO WALK MY DOG OUTSIDE AT NIGHT
WITHOUT BEING SCARED.
YOU KNOW?
APARTMENTS, THEY ARE SMALL.
EVERYONE HAS A SMALL APARTMENT
IN NEW YORK -- WELL, MOST
PEOPLE.
NOT EVERYONE IS YOU, GREG.
YOU HAVE TO GO OUT AND DO STUFF.
IF YOU ARE A WOMAN, YOU'RE BY
YOURSELF, YOU HAVE TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT GOING OUT AND DOING STUFF,
SO THE NEW DISSIDENT HOME.
WITH YOUR HUSBAND.
>> Greg: I TOLD YOU -- >> NO,
WE ARE VERY HAPPY.
>> Greg: YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN AND THE SENSE THAT
SOMEBODY LIKE YOU OR ANY OF US
CAN MOVE BUT THERE ARE ELDERLY
PEOPLE HERE, THERE ARE POOR
PEOPLE THAT GREW UP HERE THAT
CAN'T GO ANYWHERE AND THEY HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THIS STUFF.
THE LITTLE OLD LADY CAN'T GO TO
THE CBS ANY MORE BECAUSE NONE OF
HER STUFF IS THERE OR SHE WILL
GET PUSHED AND KILLED.
TYRUS, IT WAS MORE LIKE A
STATEMENT THAN A QUESTION.
>> YEAH, BECAUSE I'M NOT TRYING
TO PUSH AND KILL ANY OLD LADIES
ANY TIME SOON.
IT'S NOT REALLY COST-EFFECTIVE.
DOESN'T GET THE RESPECT IT USED
TO.
WHAT YOU WENT FOR?
I GOT THREE GRANDMAS.
MY GOD.
>> Greg: IT IS WEIRD THAT IT
IS -- I THOUGHT THAT WAS OFF
LIMITS.
>> I'VE BEEN GIVING THIS A LOT
OF THOUGHT BECAUSE -- WE DON'T
REALLY TALK ABOUT THE SHOW YOU
GET A RUNDOWN -- BUT THE JOKE IS
KIND OF ON US.
IN YOUR MONOLOGUE YOU MADE A
GREAT POINT BECAUSE WE ARE
SLOWLY -- WHEN THEY KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THE COUP THAT HAPPENED
JANUARY 6, THERE IS A COUP
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW TO OUR
AMERICAN WAY OF LIFE WHERE WE
ARE TRYING TO BE TURNED INTO A
WELFARE STATE WHERE AMERICANS
ONLY HANG OUT AROUND THEIR
MAILBOX FOR THEIR CHECKS AND
THAT IS THAT.
WHY GO TO WORK?
I WENT TO GET GAS THIS WEEK.
IT WAS $100 -- AND IT STOPS.
WHICH MEANS MY TRUCK WAS STILL
NOT FILLED UP BECAUSE IT STOPS
AT 100.
I'M LUCKY I HAVE A GOOD CAREER
BUT FOR JOE AND ANNA WHO ARE
PAYING TAXES THEY ARE GETTING
KILLED.
WHEN YOU TAKE ALL THE WORKING
AWAY.
YOU LET ALL THE MINOR CRIMINALS
OUT SO WE ARE HEARING ABOUT
MURDER BUT I COULDN'T IMAGINE
WHAT ASSAULT -- ASSAULT RATE IS
UP.
ALL THESE THINGS PEOPLE ARE
REPORTING BECAUSE THERE IS NO
ONE COMING TO THE DOOR.
SO THE COUP IS NOT JANUARY 6TH,
IT IS RIGHT NOW AND WE NEED TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
GETS OUT AND VOTES AND DOES
SOMETHING TO STOP THAT WHAT IS
GOING ON BECAUSE IT IS SCARY AND
I'M A 6'8" GUY WHO OWNS A
[BLEEP] TON OF GUNS AND WILL NOT
TAKE ANYONE FROM MESSING WITH ME
BUT NOT EVERYBODY IS ME.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.